hallo ihr redet bereitete einige leute
meine damen und herren ich zeige euch
heute meinen ankleidezimmer erst mal die
klamotten was ich so trage kulturmesse
ich viele leute haben über längeren
zeitraum immer geschrieben helga zeigt
aber eine komplette wohnung das ding ist
man kennt meine komplette wohnung zu
drehen eigentlich an allen stellen immer
irgendwelche videos das sind noch was
ich euch noch nie so richtig gezeigt
habe dass mein ankleidezimmer und ich
dachte auch wirklich bisher nie das ist
ähnlich von belangen sei weil ich bin
kein session youtuber so der content den
ich mache ist meistens eigentlich nur
scheiße in der tat allerdings mag ich
halt klamotten und markus nicht
anzuziehen und hat sich an der und haare
auf instagram ist schon seit einiger
zeit wie man mal in mehr als 80 mal so
in die richtung und outfit mäßig blabla
so bilder hochgeladen oder vermeinte hat
einige leute hier und da zeigt mal deine
ganzen klamotten und kleiderschrank
viele leute waren halt auch so teure
klamotten so verstehe ich überhaupt
nicht bis heute zeit verständlich aber
ich möchte euch mit diesem video auch
gar nicht sagen von wegen enge ich hab
sogar eine karotten sowie das vielleicht
andere machen oder bei diesen ist der
rausdorfer straße soll
ich würde ich einfach zeigen dass die
mehrzahl der dinge die ich mir gekauft
haben die teuer sind und deswegen würde
ich sagen darf
wir fangen einfach an den sneaker mal
eben sneaker bin ich dann hätte ich
feiere ich übertrieben sich hat sich
eine ganz lange zeit lang wird sich wohl
in dieses modell der welt trage ich seit
fünf jahren durchgängig und habe ich
drei ja auch nur getragen ich habe
wirklich so dass ich wert auf sneaker
läge erst seit zwei jahren also die
augen school während black white sind
auf jeden fall meine hand rassisten
schule die alle bequemsten schuhe ich
bin hier was ihr sonst hause habe sind
die valencianer betrags nation idioten
wollen noch weit von like feierlich sehr
sehr krass sagt ist nur dass mit dem
schon mal vorne ein bisschen wehtut
deswegen trage ich die gar nicht mehr so
weit will hier ist der trailer williams
schule in kooperation mit adidas
den hat mir dazu geschickt dachte ich
der wersau bequemen also er ist auch
echt heftig wie camera di sole ist so
richtig komisch mütze löchern daran muss
man sich erst dran gewöhnen dann habe
ich hier noch sonst noch in allen schon
der ist auch ultra bequem hier unten die
sind also der jetzt wirklich der ist
komplett auseinander kommen hinten die
iso oder die schon abgeblättert ich habe
ihn auch schon so oft geboten habe ich
mir letztes jahr kanada gekauft
denn hier habe ich auch zu mir
zugelaufen das ist in der international
ist dann habe ich hier den air force auf
balken nike auf eine sehr sehr sehr
bequemer schon feierlich übertrieben
weil die einfach so ich weiß die ende
mich so ein bisschen fußballschuhe
dann habe ich hier meine ließ das sind
die orte wie sie es hier sind die weißen
hieß ja die habe ich bei diesem riesigen
drop damals gekauft und auch sehr sehr
bequeme schuhe das hier sind schuhe wie
in denen ich auch oft tatsächlich angel
arbeit werde auf der straße
das sind die presto es allerdings
wichtig komplett schwarzer und die
komplett weise sondern die ersten und
ihr seht schon an den ganzen schule hier
näher die sind alle echt wirklich so ich
bin schwul sind zu tragen da und nicht
zum rumstehen und und sammeln und keine
ahnung dass ich auf jeden fall sein
sneaker die sagen ich war ganz cool sind
im kommen jetzt allerdings mit
ankleidezimmer ist erstmal hier ist so
schlafzimmer bereich jetzt alles habt
ihr glaube ich alles noch nie so richtig
gesehen so detailliert erst mal an
kleine zu lernen
[Musik]
ja meine lieben freunde das hier ist
mein ankleidezimmer megson die akustik
ist hier viel viel besser weil er halt
so viel kleidung hängt das ist
tatsächlich als ich in dieser wohnung
her gezogen bin und ich noch nicht zu
dem wert auf klamotten gelegt habe war
dieses zimmer nahezu komplett leer
ich hatte ein paar schubladen folgt wir
jetzt wirklich also jedes fach hier
fällt irgendwie aus allen nähten
ich glaube es ist wirklich so ok juli wo
und hat mittlerweile auch hier hat halt
auch ein paar schokoladen folge quatsch
ich glaube es ist aber wirklich so je
mehr platz mann hat in irgendeiner
schublade ezb rat ist um mehr sachen
packt man da auch rein so naja ich will
sagen gefahren direkt mal an das erste
ps was ihr euch zeigen möchte ist mein
lieblingswetter das ist hier der smiley
der bunte smileys wetter.de der kommt am
ersten 12 mein job meine damen und
herren
also ja erst zwölfter so ein bisschen
back to basic kollektion jedoch 2007
ihre autogrammkarten zum aller ersten
mal mich wird allerdings machen direkt
hatte diese sachen hier die sind das ist
so mein buntes fach trage ich oft nur
für videos weil das knallige farben sind
hier seien orangen des supreme shop das
hat so ein bisschen so ein handtuch
stoff einfach sein blaues t-shirt vom
weekday oder so hier ist anti social
club leute bestellt nie bei anti social
social day fliegt da einfach du wartest
wirklich auch die sache ein halbes jahr
so ich hab den support so oft
geschrieben es gibt ja auch diese jobs
anti shipping shipping klar also dass
sind auf jeden fall meine sachen die so
ein bisschen bunt sind dann habe ich
hier so beese sache nicht häufig habe
ich mir auch einfach nur klamotten
gekauft für videos sondern knalliges
orange in dem video wirkt einfach
krasser als wenn ich jetzt so ein
schwarzes shirt an habe die habe ich
dann noch so sachen so von drake das war
tour match habe ich auch richtig lange
drauf gewartet
hier den habe ich mir in amerika gekauft
in los angeles mit max das ist von tyler
the creator die marke und den darf man
gar nicht zeigen da kommt dass demnächst
ein paar sachen so gut
hier sind so schnürsenkel auch von den
von den oft sachen die schule ist es
dann habe ich gar nichts hier habe ich
mal rechnungen trainiert ist meine
schublade für alles mögliche was ja
natürlich aber auch sportsachen arminia
bielefeld trikot ob ihr nun allerdings
erstmal zu dem was glaube ich die
meisten leute interessiert das
hier vorne die sachen hier sind nämlich
alle sachen für die ich wirklich viel
geld ausgegeben habe sage ich mal hier
zu einer meiner absoluten lieblings
shirts das ist auch der aufwand
kollektion thinks hinten mit diesem
standard aufwand hatte ich ehrlich
gesagt schon länger nicht anders ich
hier noch voll so die die fall streifen
das war tatsächlich das erste t shirt in
meinem kompletten leben wo ich einen
dreistelligen betrag für ausgegeben habe
ich glaube das waren 190 euro oder so
aber feiere ich einfach heftig vom
design und ich mag die marke aufbaut
auch ich mag virgil aplomb ich war ja
dass die stadt auf jeden fall
übertrieben
das hier ist ein hu die da kommen wir
direkt zuerst im leveldesign hier mit
der freiheitsstatue das ding bei diesem
hobby ist das hatte ich auch schon bei
kilian im bio glaube ich gesagt die
tasche die star eingenäht normalerweise
für den taschen von rudis irgendwie
immer so dann sind die hier irgendwie so
drauf gepackt oder so und bei dem jedes
ist einfach da rein in das ding rein und
dadurch hält sich der polymer den andern
dreht er sich um und der sieht doch von
innen gegen die das sind so ganz viele
komische layers irgendwie ganz ganz
komisch wenn man den an hart gegen die
also das war ein absoluter fehlkauf
freunde ihr merkt schon werde ich ein
produkt feier dann sage ich das wenn ich
ein produkt komplett scheiß finden dann
sage ich das auch und das ist halt
komplett scheiße so wie gerade schon
gesagt das shirt hiervon abweichende
megageil diesen rudi hilfreich zum
beispiel auch übertrieben denn hat mir
eine instagram seite sieht movement
showdown bei den betrieben von dem
design das ist auch heute nein das ist
nicht das erste mal das ist ein motto
noch zusammen gemacht haben nicht nur
sneaker und dessen überschrift mit
s.oliver schrift feierlich auf jeden
fall auch übertrieben dieses stück hier
kommen wir nun zu einem weiteren viel
kraft das ist das erste produkt was mir
von gucci gekauft habe jemals und der
kragen ist so ausbleibt ich meine guckt
euch das man da passt kein kopf zwei mal
rein wenn ich darunter ein t shirt an
haben möchte wohl irgendwas zum lehren
was weißes oder so dann siehst du das
komplette stadt so ich brauche ein shirt
mit v ausschnitt damit du das weißt du
nicht siehst und das ding ist auch the
debtors abgegangen denn irgendwie mal
was mit sein sollte so wird schärfer
sagt hey der speck oder so wir vorne
liegt tatsächlich noch das links rum
also das hier ist einfach abgerissen ich
weiß nicht was da für eine qualität es
auch die ärmel die sind so ausbleiben
weil die pasta wir haben dreimal rein
die sind so ausgeleiert also no shit
leute ich habe mir zwei mal was von
gucci gekauft die sie kiesswetter weil
ich das design einfach cool fand und es
steht nicht gut ski vorne drauf so wenn
man den im winter anhalt mit einer jacke
dann sieht man gar nicht dass der von
gucci ist ich schäme mich halt so ein
bisschen für diese marke so ich würde
auch nie was von louie vito kaufen weil
ich die sachen einfach bisher komplett
schon beschissen finde und das ist der
zweite wurde ihm ein zweites produkt was
ich von gucci habe genau das gleiche der
kragen leider immer weiter aus hier
vorne da passt beinahe wieder viermal
diese gummis keine ahnung wenn ich das
einmal ziehe so daten da passten kam er
rein ansonsten finde ich dass die seine
aufgabe und das ist halt der einzige
grund warum ich mir die beiden sachen
gekauft habe das ding ist übrigen wieder
abgegangen
hier zwei von diesen guten teil habe ich
hier rum liegen die sind beide einfach
rausgerissen als die rausgezogen hat
also no shit leute das kommt jetzt hier
so rüber als wenn dieses video hier nur
dazu da um irgendwie klamotten marken
fertig zu machen denn ich habe auch
coole sachen tatsächlich aber diese
beiden sachen a das war für mich das
zeichen luca kauft ihr nie wieder was
von gut chinas gemacht meinen du hast
nie angekommen wird so brachte mich hier
wieder jürgen davon ab zusammen der die
jacke konnte ich ja zum glück noch
zurück sind aber ich würde sagen wir
machen direkt weiter mit dem nächsten
produkt ein massiger vorne habe das ist
mit dieser die das wetter echt günstig
eigentlich dafür dass ist und das ding
ist sogar das ist einer meiner
lieblingswörter ist wenn ich sogar mein
absoluter lieblingsfilm der ist schlicht
simpel aber der schnitt ist cool hier
und das ist auch ein bisschen locker
aber das passt bei der ganzen schnitt
ein bisschen lockerer megageil live
stream feierlich übertrieben
dann war ich in paris und habe mir bei
valencia gab das shirt gekauft was ich
auch mega geil finde bin ich aber ein
ganz gutes design schlicht simpel
gehalten ist auch übel oversize das ding
mit valencia ist allerdings auch dass
ich mir auch in paris einen rucksack
gekauft weil ich nie einen richtigen
rucksack habe ich hab mir den gekauft
und was ist natürlich direkt passiert
der reißverschluss kaputt gegangen nicht
den rucksack hierzu machen will seht ihr
schon okay geht eigentlich alles aber so
also ich war wirklich in berlin gekauft
hatte keine probleme war dann in
amsterdam mit ein paar freunden hatten
diesen rucksack und hatte damals
drin und da mal eine jacke in dieser
reißverschluss drin und wir haben die
nicht rausbekommen dir sagst denn der
hotellobby mit seife mit logen mit allen
möglich haben das versucht da raus zu
kriegen wir mussten dann noch samstags
abends einen schneider wach klingeln der
mir das ding repariert hat für 50 euro
und der meint so gailer rucksack alter
also halt auf niederländisch aber meine
jahr folge eines dieser ich war
übertrieben aber den reißverschluss der
ist echt der ist komplett beschlossen
zudem würde ich zurückgeben von daher
werde ich demnächst mal in serie auf
jeden fall mal kontaktieren
bezüglich des rucksacks weil sonst ich
feiere die sache übertrieben qualitativ
hochwertig aber der rucksack echt
komplett scheiße machen wir weiter mit
meinem nächsten ps das war der erste
teure wo die idee nicht mehr gekauft
habe das war so lorang und den habe ich
tatsächlich nur wegen den dieser
eingekauft wegen diesem ausgewaschenen
sogar hier in den kordeln drin das war
in hamburg damals und ich habe mir
gedacht okay das design der muss ich
haben hatte den an so beim autofahren
allah und das eine echt coole dann hatte
ich den namen als ich in köln war fünf
tage und hab mir einfach nur so
wer sitzt eigentlich komplett beschissen
deswegen würde ich den auf jeden fall
nicht nochmal kaufen vom schnitt her ist
ja echt irgendwie ein bisschen komisch
kann auch sein dass daran liegt dass
sich ein kompletter lappen bin
allerdings keine ahnung also vom design
finde ich den mega cool den auf jeden
fall war mein erster rudi für den ich
wirklich auch im höheren dreistelligen
betrag ausgegeben habe dann der hier der
geld tatsächlich meint es also den da
der mir gegeben werden nicht mehr trägt
also ja es ist ein stinknormaler stone
island wo die ich will hier gar nicht so
krass aufpreise eingehen also ich hab
bisher glaube ich noch gar keinen preis
sei nur bei dem auch forscher genau was
190 euro kostet ich glaube jeder kann
sich denken was ein gutes wetter kostet
oder was in valencia kostet so soll
nicht um die preise gehen es soll
einfach heute darum gehen auf euch nicht
unbedingt teure produkte um irgendwie
cooler zu sein so es macht keinen sinn
solltest entwicklung die ich jetzt erst
realisieren so zum beispiel dieser
valencia rückstand der war echt heftig
teuer und jetzt schickt ihn einfach
zurück weil dieses ding einfach
qualitativ scheiße passiert ist es doch
eine fleecejacke die ist rita sowie kann
man umdrehen und auch von der seite an
dann kann man das schild ja abknöpfen
das ding ist ich glaube das kennt jeder
man geht denn irgendeinen klamotten
geschäfts und guckt sich das allerdings
sich ja das werde ich anziehen hatte ich
hatte ich nie an die jacke die letzte
sagen wir die vollkommenheit und habe
ist dieser stinknormale schlichtes
schwarzes wetter
der war runtergesetzt auf glaube ich 150
euro habe ich direkt zuschlagen dem fall
nicht wirklich mega der ist einfach
schlicht und ich mag es einfach weiß ich
nicht denn wenn sachen einfach schlicht
sind nicht so krass hin herr bieber dass
er auch jetzt kommen wir direkt zum
nächsten show etwas so das komplette
gegenteil von schlecht ist dann habe ich
sehr sehr häufig in videos an wo ich mir
einfach gedacht aber ich hab den letzten
videos nur rot schwarz weiß also muss
man wieder was gelbes anziehen und dann
schreiten immer leute in die kommentare
hey vorher verwirrend ist wird in der
hand hier irgendwie so den feiere ich
auf jeden fall das ding ist man kann dem
nicht mit vielen sachen kombinieren
weil er halt komplett knall ich geld ist
kommen wir nun da war es auch zu einmal
der lieblingsstadt uns war das hier das
ist das oft wild galaxy fit dingsbums
ich habe überhaupt keine ahnung ist auf
jeden fall aus der dance collection den
mega geil das design ist wenn man drüber
fühlt dass wir sie so anders war das mit
kleber irgendwie drauf geklebt das logo
immer das design feiere ich auch
übertrieben ist also vom design her
wirklich eines der krassesten krassesten
produkte dieses ich mir gekauft habt ihr
merkt schon leute in diesem video das
ist sehr sehr krass fashion bezogen habe
ich hab selber nicht so die größte
ahnung solche leute wie justin oder
kilian oder victor oder keine ahnung der
mit dem bin ich allen cool
die werden mich alle hätten hierfür weil
ich so sagen ja das ist hierbei wird
spaßig irgendwie auch boden habe ich bin
ganz ehrlich so ich möchte euch einfach
nur zeigen was meinem kleiderschrank ist
unter kieren hatte das video hat eine
halbe mehrere aufrufe weshalb mehr als
ein bisschen gezeigt hey das sind
wirklich leute interessiert daran was
sich in meinem kleiderschrank befindet
sorry auf jeden fall dass das ganze
video ein bisschen länger ist aber wie
gesagt wenn ihr keine zeit mir habt dann
auch gern pause und schaut das video und
weiter regiert wird will das sieht der
erste auf bartoli die nicht mehr gekauft
habe und das sieht man auch schon hier
ist das ding ist einfach abgegangen
diese dieses gewicht standard auf wald
wo die den martin garrigues auch relativ
häufig anhang feierte ich auf jeden fall
auch übertrieben denn ich muss dir
endlich mal anschreiben das mir so eine
kordel dings punkt zurückgeben
das hier absolut der fehlkauf bei
morsche paris viel zu teuer für seine
qualität ich krieg das nicht raus ich
weiß nicht was das ist das verfährt sich
einfach
jetzt so beschissen vom schnitt her es
ist so kurz diese er werde das ist so
cool er komplett kacke ich werde nie
wieder was von ballymore kaufen kommen
in unserem letzten of peace was ich habe
das ist dass der tempelritter kollektion
es war nicht einfach ganz cool mit dem
design weil das halt so irgendwie cross
blabla der trage ich aber tatsächlich
auch nie weil man wirklich wie gesagt
geld kann man sehr kann ich sehr
schlecht kombinieren dann haben wir
vorne noch zwei so jobs keine ahnung
die sind komplett zu gestaubt das sind
einfach sachen von the bachelor fall
haben wir hier zu einer schublade von
mir mit allen möglichen sachen zum
drunter anziehen also dass hier sind
alles weiße t shirts zum lern finde ich
sehr wichtig hier noch irgendwie so ein
die spreadshirt alles weiße sachen
wirklich das ist von der tipa die
kampagne ich habe einer kampagne
mitgemacht die gegen cybermobbing ist es
war sehr sehr sehr sehr cool aber da
werdet ihr demnächst was denn hier sind
dann die schwarzen shirts das ist vom
von tyler the creator sticker sind so
paasch tatsachen classics hier sind so
mehr die basics sachen drin sage ich mal
also man kann die was von hier oben um
beispielsweise nehmen das war es meine
intention ok schwarzen sweater dann kann
ich hier in weiße shirt nehmen und hier
drunter boxershorts socken
ich meine die beste sorgten darunter
befinden sich die hosen da habe ich hier
repräsentiere die fand ich ganz cool mit
dem streifen des dings der streifen ab
gegangen so der kleber da geht hier ab
meine mama hat das gilt auch hier bei
der reprise auch so hier einfach nicht
drin
also rief riesenfeier ich auf jeden fall
übertrieben es vom design die hosen von
vor dem aussehen einfach aber qualitativ
auch echt kacke keine ahnung würde ich
auf jeden fall nicht normal laufen hier
sind ein paar rosen der tk damals
umsonst zugeschickt das war auf jeden
fall auch sehr nett von den ganz unten
habe ich noch kein passwörter einfach
auch tyler ganz normale rudi roth das
wird justin bieber mit viel mehr sachen
habe ich eigentlich gar nicht mehr zu
zeigen hier sind schlaff shirts drin
hier unten sind dies also aus meinem
popieluszko der konnte am ersten 12
hier unten sind so ein paar normale wo
dies doch drin hier auch erster zwölfter
meinem shop 12 das hier sind alle
schubladen von julia versionen sind
meine karnevalskostüme über das gericht
am 11.11
das war so krass alter ja das ist auf
jeden fall die karte weils schublade
dass sie fordern was ich noch alles
umhängen das sind auch sachen aus meinem
shop hier das ist die jeansjacke aus
meinen job hier hängen einfach nur
sachen wo ich wirklich kein bock habt
die auf zu verhalten und schrank zu
legen sondern hier hängen auch viele
weiße shirt pulli ist relativ viel north
face tasche die fertigkeit ganz gut die
theoretisch mit dem auffälligen
verbinden was gar nicht komplett
unterschiedliche gelbtöne wir sind auf
jeden fall so taschen und koffer hier
ist ein kleiner rimowa kupfer hier ist
ein großteil sind julius käufer des
handgepäcks koffer hier sind ein paar
sachen von judith jetzt ja so
wintersachen jetzt so balenciaga mit zu
unseren oft hier sind noch geheim ich
trage eigentlich nahezu nikabs ich
glaube die krake wird die hier sein dass
dies klappt hat in letzter zeit ein
bisschen meine haare so lange wie du
dich bisschen länger wachsen lassen will
aber sonst war's das auch eigentlich
schon von meinem anteil der zimmer hier
steht wirklich nur schwach sind um so
wäscheständer so ein paar alte sachen
von jule hier so das sind schubladen von
mir hier sind beispielsweise ganz viele
brauchst du denn hier sind noch so
tastaturen ipad ist noch drin also ganz
viele verschiedene sachen
hier ist echt cool oder ja sonst gibt es
gar nicht mehr viel zu zeigen freunde
mich haben tüten und kartons habe ich
eine auf privat hier vorne und so auch
gerade weil so dieser einzigen für
diesen beiden saga karton so ist es
einfach cool finde ich das stellt man
sich gerne hinter schaut man gerne an
dessen oben eso fächer wo man nie so
wirklich was hin packt wo man nicht
wirklich hin greifen würde
ja das ist tatsächlich mein
ankleidezimmer das ist noch immer aber
ich trage nie händen die sind nach farbe
sortiert da sieht man wie selten nicht
in frage da hier kommt auch am ersten
zwölften stock summa summarum liegt aber
im endeffekt nehmen
jetzt wollen ich hätte jetzt doch auch
parfums eingehen können und
sonnenbrillen und noch mehr auf schule
weil ich habe halt die gesagt vorne noch
ein paar stunden später aber ich glaube
dass videos auch so schon viel zu lange
das ist dass anträge gegen wie das nicht
wirklich wert auf klamotten lege und ich
hätte nie gedacht dass euch das
irgendwie so krass interessiert doch in
letzter zeit kamen viele kommentare dem
thema um tue auch an kleinen zimmer und
beck fliehen
das video wegen mega und gab also schaut
auch gerne vorbei ich hoffe euch das
video gefallen ist das getan hat las
gerne ein leiter habt ihr vielleicht
tipps für mich wie ich beispielsweise
diese gute sache der heide bekomme oder
ob ich bei auch heute den schreiber kann
wegen dem dem komischen blümel den da
ich sollte wirklich kein video sein das
möchte ich direkt klar stellen wo ich
sage hey guck mal das ist so teuer dass
das foto janicki haben wird uns ein
vergessen also dass hier vorne ist der
schrank für jacken meine damen und
herren hier hat juni die jacken
wir hab ich noch lachen
hier ist eine lederjacke das ist einem
klaren ja klar ich mir gekauft für einen
stolzen betrag eine woche später auf dem
laden vorbei da mal die jacke zur hälfte
runtergesetzt also dass wir sind auf
jeden fall die jacken
das sind eigentlich normal jacken arten
drin die jeder hat also in der
regenjacke winterjacke die bereits
gesagt ich möchte weg sind das ist kein
video sein soll von wegen hey 10.000
euro fashion week auch in den kopf wie
viel geld für klamotten was ist das
gegenteil der fall sein weingut sie sagt
ich habe einfach kompletten tag des
jahres zeigt ist komplett paket durch
das doppelte ausgegeben obwohl sie
eigentlich die hälfte werden ist also
ich habe vieles falsch gemacht glaube
ich was klamotten angeht aber ja ich
schreibe gerne eure meinung meinen stil
zwei karotten und in die kommentare
hat euch gefallen ich weiß nicht wer
jetzt ein sehr sehr langes video am
erstens läuft bereits
da kommen verschiedene neue klamotten in
meinen job fünf produkte kommen rein 1
wetter 2 bis 1 liter und ein
schulmädchen tatsächlich schaut also
kehrt am ersten zwölf gefilmt sondern
eine shop vorbei und jetzt kommt das
auto und sorry dass ich euch so lange
gelagert haben
[Musik]